it is jackie robinson day and night
around baseball everybody including max
shearers are wearing that number 42
to honor the man who broke baseball's
color barrier kevin pollard
half swing line drive one three double
play
that will put an end to the bottom of
the second
so the nats do turn their 25th double
play of the year in rather unusual
fashion now it's up to trey turner to
get his ball club ahead here
that was center cut and a high bouncer
that'll drive in a couple and trey
turner thinking too
ferdugo picks it up nats lead 2-nothing
and for trey turner a 13-game
hitting streak easy double for trey
turner i wonder if he decides to steal
third here even though juan soto's up
we'll see doesn't swing 3-0 very often
but this is the park and situation to do
it if he's thinking about it
and soto pulls one high in the ear to
right pillar back
see
you
later
the monster's a little shorter and right
but you got to hit it a whole lot
farther in the nats lead four-nothing on
soto's ninth and now we dance juan soto
ladies and gentlemen not much more to
say
how he gets one center cut high in the
air
see you
later
second row above the green monster and
howie has two on the year and then
that's lead by five oh here we go clutch
look at you guys
raphael never struck out looking in the
first inning next double for raphael
will be his 100th could have had it the
other night but he got a triple he could
have stopped at second could have
already cleared the bases with that
rocket that he hit into the alley
up against the wall
here comes verdugo
he's chugging around trying to score the
throw to the plate is cut and there is
that 100th double
just as scripted and the red sox are on
the board
to make it 5-1
on the move turner
throw there in plenty of time trying to
get into a rundown and let's see what
the umpires say yes the run scored
[Applause]
so they tried to do that the other day
with luis garcia the steal and stop with
two strikes
and you didn't think they'd try it with
juan soto but they did and they just
stole the run goley taylor with a chance
for a two-out rbi here
and taylor robbed by bogarts
little double pump out is the call
and the gnats will certainly take a look
at that stay safe it's a bad call
seven to one
what do you say we're watching a hall of
famer folks that's ten strikeouts for
max scherzer for the 97th time
in his future hall of fame career
fourth time this year for max he punches
out double digits don't see backward k's
too often with max but he locks up
bogarts here with a beautiful change up
just strikeout number 11 for max cersei
josh harrison one for three a tough luck
one for three
jackie bradley jr robbed him of at least
a double out in center field
he got a fastball deep to center
straightaway bradley
see you later
into the batter's eye straight away
center at fenway and josh is second as
annette
makes it 9-1
second home run of the season that ball
was ripped well here's another guy
having a good night trey turner two run
double anabasa
seventh
net to bat in the unit
and that will move by moreland
i think taylor will score easily
second double of the night for trey
turner he's gotten them an interesting
fashion a bouncer over third and a
squibber down the line ten to one as we
go to the bottom of the ninth so zooey
lynn will bat for the first time and
that's gonna be ball four a plucky to
bat for the first time ben bramer making
his major league debut tonight
that one tag on a line into the ten
right back to taylor
lynn on his way into third base gonna be
a lengthy single for flowecky and
they're gonna be on at first and third
swung on and missed he went fishing one
man gone in the red sox ninth inning
first career strikeout for bremer
went down to get it up the middle for a
base hit that'll bring in a run
zoo wayland will score from third
lowecky up to second so pilar has
seen the end of his oprah 13. first and
second for jackie bradley jr looking for
an rbi here tonight he's going to drive
that one into center field it falls down
for a base hit but lolecki has to stop
at third so
that will load the bases red sox with
their best offensive inning of the ball
game i think davey's going to come get
him now so two outs here's verdugo
and another one sky to center
row blaze broke back comes in and defo
right in front of him will take it and
the nats in a route win big in boston